- I have two Gushers in my hand still.
(whips)
(metallic creaking)
(upbeat electronic music)
- I smoked a caviar cone, which is a joint
that has hash oil in it.
- I smoked seven joints this morning.
No, it was maybe four, maybe five.
- What?
- We just smoked a small joint
and another small joint.
- Smoked two blunts, I feel great.
High as mug.
- Are you guys stoned?
- Fruit rollups.
- Gushers.
- Dipping, dunking, swooshing.
- The cheese and cracker
version of Dunkaroos.
- Yay!
- Gushers!
- I knew it was gonna be Gushers, man.
- [Woman] Different colors --
- [Man] Classic Gusher
where they all stick
together in the plastic.
- Kinda taste like plastic.
- It's like I'm eating plastic.
- Mmm, it tastes like blue.
- It's everywhere now.
- I'm gushing.
- I can die a happy man.
- Aw.
- I can, I lived my dream.
I smoked a blunt from Snoop Dogg before.
That was my first part where
I'd be cool with dyin'.
Now this.
- Surge!
- Oh, man.
- The coolest drink ever invented.
- Kinda leaves that oily
taste in your mouth.
- [Man] Whoa.
- [Woman] Yeah, this is like
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle blood.
- [Woman] Ooh, Fun Dip.
- [Man] Ooh.
See all it --
- [Woman] Delightful!
- And it's so fun, I love when
a candy can figure out a way to make
eating it an event.
- It's like Surge.
- Ew, grody.
- Yeah, that one's not great.
- Like if someone spilled a
strawberry daiquiri on sand.
- Hey, Mom, would you grab me a Fun Dip?
The Cherry Yum Diddly Dip flavor?
- [Man] You got that paper.
- [Woman] Cherry Yum
Diddly Dip.
When I was a kid, I'd be like (bleep) you.
- No, you got me the Razz
Apple Magic Dip, Mom!
Can't you read the labels!
- You have to pretty
much stop everything else
to consume this candy.
(gasps)
- [Man] Wow!
- [Woman] Oh my God!
- Cheers.
- Tastes like tea.
- Melted popsicle.
- Mmhmm, yup, that's what this is.
- It tastes disgusting.
- I don't think it's good.
- Maybe blue raspberry?
- This kinda tastes like grape.
It doesn't even taste like blue.
- Blue, that's the flavor.
- Push Pop!
- [Woman] Oh, my Lord.
- [Man] They put a wrapper
on it.
- Are you kidding me?
This is way too involved.
- I'm glad it has a belt clip, though.
- It's not just about taste.
It's also about play.
- Another interactive
candy!
- [Man] Interactive.
- It's not about how it tastes.
It's how it makes you feel.
- I feel like an adult baby.
- I'd say that a good
thing about snacks from
- [Both] the 90s,
- Were that you could play
with them, also eat them.
- It's not.
- Essentially they're toys and snacks.
- It was more about color than flavor,
if you know what I'm saying.
- [Woman] Yeah, red.
- [Man] My favorite flavor
was red.
♫ Gushers, Gushers, they get so gushy
♫ Matter of fact, like a
marshmallow, get so mushy
♫ Matter of fact what does it remind me of
♫ This reminds me of everything
♫ I used to eat in the 90s, 'Cuz ♫
How 'bout you, Emma?
- Same.
(whips)
(metallic creaking)